[Music]
consider the spot where you're sitting
travel backwards in time and it might
have been submerged at the bottom of a
shallow sea buried under miles of rock
or floating through a molten infernal
landscape but go back far enough about
4.6 billion years and you'd be in the
middle of an enormous cloud of dust and
gas orbiting a newborn star this is the
setting for some of the biggest smallest
mysteries of physics the mysteries of
cosmic dust bunnies seemingly empty
regions of space between stars actually
contain clouds of gas and dust usually
blown there by supernovas when a dense
cloud reaches a certain threshold called
the genes mass it collapses in on itself
the shrinking cloud rotates faster and
faster and heats up eventually becoming
hot enough to burn hydrogen in its core
at this point a star is born as fusion
begins in the new star it sends out Jets
of gas that blow off the top and bottom
of the cloud leaving behind an orbiting
ring of gas and dust called a proto
planetary disc this is a surprisingly
windy place eddies of gas carry
particles apart and send them smashing
into each other the dust consists of
tiny metal fragments bits of rock and
further out ices we've observed
thousands of these discs in the sky at
various stages of development as dust
clumps together into larger and larger
masses
dust grains 100 times smaller than the
width of a human hair stick to each
other through what's called the Van der
Waals force that's where a cloud of
electrons shifts to one side of a
molecule creating a negative charge on
one end and a positive charge on the
other opposites attract but van der
waals can only hold tiny things together
and there's a problem once dust clusters
grow to a certain size the windy
atmosphere of a disk should constantly
break them up as they crash into each
other the question of how they continue
to grow is the first mystery of dust
bunnies one theory looks to
electrostatic charge to answer this
energetic gamma rays x-rays and UV
photons knock electrons off of gas atoms
within the disk creating positive ions
and negative electrons electrons run
into and stick to dust making it
negatively charged now when the wind
pushes clusters together like repels
like and slows them down as they collide
with gentle collisions they won't
fragment but if the repulsion is too
strong they'll never grow one theory
suggests that high-energy particles can
knock more electrons off of some dust
clumps leaving them positively charged
opposites again attract and clusters
grow rapidly but before long we reach
another set of mysteries we know from
evidence found in meteorites that these
fluffy dust bunnies eventually get
heated melted and then cooled into solid
pellets called
cons rules and we had no idea how or why
that happens furthermore once those
pellets do form how do they stick
together
the electrostatic forces from before are
too weak and small rocks can't be held
together by gravity either gravity
increases proportionally to the mass of
the objects involved
that's why you could effortlessly escape
an asteroid the size of a small mountain
using just the force generated by your
legs so if not gravity then what perhaps
its dust a fluffy dust rim collected
around the outside of the pellets could
act like velcro there's evidence for
this in meteors where we find many
chondrules surrounded by a thin rim of
very fine material possibly condensed
dust
eventually the chondral pellets get
cemented together inside larger rocks
which at about one kilometer across are
finally large enough to hold themselves
together through gravity they continue
to collide and grow into larger and
larger bodies including the planets we
know today ultimately the seeds of
everything familiar the size of our
planet its position within the solar
system and its elemental composition
were determined by an uncountably large
series of random collisions change the
dust cloud just a bit and perhaps the
conditions wouldn't have been right for
the formation of life on our planet now
you know what space dust is but what
makes up common household dust you might
be surprised when you take a closer look
[Music]